i feel today
as though i'm a
prisoner who after seven years and five
months has found freedom again
but my imprisonment was unbearable not
only for four years was actually in
prison but also i was
accused of being an assassin and without
an element of proof and i don't think
that anyone could possibly imagine how
you can feel what it means to see your
own life in your own family
in pieces
in pieces for nothing for no reason
whatsoever
and i read somewhere
that i wasn't expecting to be acquitted
and that's not the case
because after all this is the reality
and of course it had to finish in this
way
but at the same time after everything
that's happened over the past seven
years and five months of course i was
really scared